the border between northern ireland and
the republic is one of the most
contentious in the world
thousands have died over it
decided by politics not geography its
irregular shape looks odd
it divides roads
houses
in one place it even separates a church
from its graveyard
for an outsider looking at the irish
border it doesn't make very much sense
but it does have its own curious logic
so what's the story behind it and what
really divides ireland even after a
hundred years
this border is still deeply sensitive
[Music]
ireland's border was created in 1921
while northern ireland remained in the
united kingdom the south left
but to understand why ireland was
divided in the first place we need to go
back in time
in the 1600s the british who were mostly
protestants started colonizing catholic
ireland they took control of the north
discriminating against catholics and
other dissenters in 1798 it led to a
major rebellion
it was crushed by the british who
decided to adopt a new policy
total control
in 1801 the whole of ireland became part
of the united kingdom
for protestants in the north it was a
huge victory for catholics in the south
who wanted independence it was a
catastrophe
but it also brought a new opportunity to
influence the british government
there were no irish mps going to
westminster and those people became very
significant players in british politics
westminster became the stage for the
campaign for home rule for ireland
with politicians arguing both sides of
the debate
and back on the streets of ireland
tensions escalated
in 1916 pro-independence catholics
carried out an armed insurrection that
came to be known as the easter rising
it triggered further revolution that
turned into a war for independence
with protestant paramilitary groups in
the north fighting to remain part of the
united kingdom
in 1921 the british government ended the
war signing a treaty that gave southern
ireland independence
the treaty was signed on december 21st
and dublin showed its approval with a
colorful parade of gaelic enthusiasm but
it wasn't a complete victory for the
separatists the british government had
decided to carve the country in two
while the northern protestant
communities would remain part of the
united kingdom
the south would be free to rule itself
it radically redrew the map of the
united kingdom
and for the first time an international
border was drawn between northern
ireland and the south
there was a very simple and a very crude
calculation as to where the northern
irish border was drawn it was about
trying to have as many protestants as
possible in the north and as few
protestants as possible in the south
that's why the shape of this border is
so highly unusual
partition satisfied no one
catholics in the south could now govern
themselves but their country had been
split in two
protestants in the north had hoped the
whole of ireland would stay in the
united kingdom
and there was one group that was put in
an especially intolerable position
catholics in the north arguably lost the
most here they were trapped in a state
which they didn't want they were never
it seemed in 1921 ever going to be
sufficiently numerous to vote their way
out of this
over 400 000 catholics were now trapped
on the wrong side of the border
their plight would trigger decades of
bloodshed
in the north anti-catholic
discrimination became rife
by the late 1960s civil rights
demonstrations in america inspired
northern irish catholics to protest
peacefully for equality
but police often used brutal force to
crush the marches
and loyalist protestants targeted the
protests as well as holding their own
marches
in 1969 a confrontation at a protestant
march sparked days of clashes that
spread across northern ireland
overwhelmed northern ireland's prime
minister asked the british government
for help
british troops were sent in
it was the beginning of three decades of
violence in northern ireland now called
the troubles
in 1972 british soldiers opened fire on
catholic protesters
14 died and at least 15 were injured it
became known as bloody sunday
i was fired on by the paratroopers and
yet parliamentary democracy was such
that i was not allowed to speak
the event radicalized angry catholics
membership of republican paramilitary
groups such as the ira swelled
and deadly attacks against protestants
and british troops increased in my
opinion we cannot do without the irish
republican army
republican paramilitaries were able to
use that border to their advantage at
various points they could flee across
that border they were able to use it to
store weapons border infrastructure was
itself a target as a symbol of british
rule in ireland
in response the british armed forces
became a permanent presence at the
border and established bases elsewhere
in northern ireland
the ira argued they were fighting a
military occupation but loyalist
northern irish militias saw the border
as protection against a catholic
majority
they attacked those they deemed
republican sympathizers
we're going to turn this town in their
burning holocaust a tit-for-tat campaign
of violence began
three car bombs in quick succession
ripped through the village just a few
miles from londonderry
over the 30 years of the troubles more
than 3
700 people were killed
many many more were injured and most of
those who were killed and injured were
civilians
as headlines of attacks and atrocities
increased global leaders attempted to
promote peace the history of northern
ireland has been written in the blood
of its children and their parents
[Music]
in 1998 there was a breakthrough
today we can take a collective breath
and begin to blow away
let's hope the cobwebs of the past the
british and irish governments and most
of the political parties in northern
ireland came together to sign a landmark
deal that became known as the good
friday agreement
the deal removed the hard border between
the two countries and stated that if
majorities in both north and south
wanted to reunite ireland they could
the following two decades were
relatively stable in northern ireland
until now
in 2016 the united kingdom voted to
leave the european union
it opted for a complete break ending
free movement of people and goods
as part of the uk northern ireland would
also have to leave
but with the republic of ireland still a
member and the border between the two
countries now fairly open there was a
problem
as they were now governed by different
rules again the obvious solution was to
re-establish a hard border
a move no one wanted
the only other option would be a de
facto trade border in the irish sea
separating northern ireland from the
rest of the uk
this proposal was called the northern
irish protocol and it removed the need
for a hard border
but northern irish loyalists weren't
happy
we are totally opposed to the protocol
we will neither accept it
nor will we work it at the same time
increasing numbers of northern irish are
welcoming unity with the south
there is this growing center ground of
people who may or may not be religious
people who have grown up in peace and
who don't understand the um the forces
which drove northern ireland into
conflict who don't identify with them
these changes might make a united
ireland more feasible
but they could also reignite old
tensions in the north one of the things
which concerns and many people in
northern ireland whatever their view on
irish unity
is that if we did have a vote in favor
of irish unity particularly a narrow
vote in favor of irish unity that that
could precipitate violence in northern
ireland and as difficult and fraught as
the brexit process was in the
um rest of the uk there was never any
serious prospect of
riots on the streets of london of people
being killed of bombs going off in
northern ireland that would be a very
real possibility and perhaps a
probability
thanks for watching to read more of the
economist's coverage of northern ireland
and the irish border click the link and
don't forget to subscribe
you